one year since rigged elections saw
alexander lukashenko kitted out in full
assault gear as his security forces
launched a full-scale crackdown on his
people
he was on fighting form again with this
response
to fresh uk sanctions you can choke on
those sanctions in the uk
we haven't had the faintest idea for a
millennia about great britain
and we don't want to you're america's
lap dogs
six and a half hours in i got to ask my
question
i saw people incredibly badly beaten
there are reports of torture
across your detention centers not just
in a crestina
and there has been no accountability for
that and there are tens of thousands of
people who have fled your regime
for fear i've spoken to people here they
are all
scared respected dear lady
oh christina is not a sanatorium full
stop
[Applause]
secondly i'm very glad that you informed
me that those who committed crimes in
belarus
and ran away to you with whom you're
talking are afraid
minsk now is quiet people scared to put
a foot wrong
security onto us fast we're a tv crew
from
british to the nice guy news and we're
here but our accreditation
save us this time
here just the remnants of the red and
white flag the symbol of last year's
protests which now can get you jailed
after police pushed protesters off the
street they started to gather
in neighborhood courtyards and in this
particular one in november last year a
local resident was so badly beaten by
government thugs
that he fell into a coma and later died
in hospital
since then the crackdown has only
intensified which means that now
nobody goes out onto the streets or into
courtyards like this to protest anymore
roman bondarenko was his name and olga
is his cousin
she tells me of the many small ways in
which she and his mother lena
are being watched
recently my aunt lena saw a drone flying
up to her window and filming
every night you go to bed and you think
looks like i'm still alive i am still
free
and we'll see what happens tomorrow and
when you wake up you think oh good
nobody came to me last night
we meet nina the grandmother of the
protests
who stood up over and over again to law
enforcement
and who's still unafraid to say what she
thinks about alexander lukashenko
there's no point in taking him to court
as he is ill mentally ill
that's what doctors say he needs
treatment let him stay at home and get
better
watch tv and read books
but those in the hall today gave
lukashenko the message he wanted to hear
a fawning display of support for a man
convinced the westerout to get him
and incredibly out of touch with the
mood of so many of his people
dynamagne sky news